what's up guys Happy New Year hope
you're having a good one and have some
great goals for this new year well for
me I'm going to try to release uh nice
steady videos this year that's that's
the big thing for this channel uh today
we're going to go over the strategy
pattern and the strategy design pattern
I'm going to code it up in C plus plus
and give you a generic example but
basically what this does is it kind of
allows you to swap out algorithms or
functions rather on the Fly
so that if you're working with something
and you want to do it a different way
for whatever reason
then you can so generally what you need
is some sort of
um set of data we'll say that you pass
into a function and
you know your function will execute that
being say strategy or algorithm one and
then if you want to switch that you can
have another version of this function
that does the still the same call but
executes a different option now of
course the Brute Force way of doing this
is if else probably don't want to do if
else too much you can if you want to but
I'm kind of learning it initially from
this website not bad we'll go over super
quickly here because this is pretty
generic so you want to interface that
has a virtual method method of execute
or call whatever you want executes a
fine name and then you can inherit from
this interface and if you watch the
other design pattern and stuff you'll
know kind of where this is going then
you implement those different interfaces
with different strategies and then later
we'll make a class and one of its
members is going to be this strategy
interface and we can set it to any
concrete one that we've implemented and
then you know once we're running the
real thing we can
we can just call it we can call xq
strategy and it's going to execute the
current one if we want to change the
strategy we can pass in a different
strategy so uh yeah that's a quick
summary let's go ahead and code it up so
I'm going to go ahead and you know I'm
on the design patterns repo link down
below if you need it and we're going to
just make some new stuff I'm going to
add a new folder and we'll call this one
strategy
I know a lot of you have liked seeing
this being related to like video game
stuff so maybe we could do it in that
method of a video game type of strategy
uh so let me think of something on that
now you know we could have like a
strategy for executing normal attacks
and a strategy for executing critical
attacks but the problem I foresee with
that is that well we don't necessarily
want to be swapping pointers every time
there's a crit and then swapping back
every time there's not that would just
be too many swaps usually you want to
swap once and kind of leave it there for
a while and then swap it back if
something major changes that's going to
stay changed you don't want to swap it
like every frame or something that would
be incredibly intensive for something
that's running in a loop and supposed to
be efficient so let's think of something
else okay let's let's consider leveling
um let's think of something like okay
you know a lot of games you like level
and ability and as you level it the
ratios of things change and the
algorithm that calculates this damage
might change so let's consider something
like that and let's just do a couple
levels and switch it on on that so all
right let's just uh keep it a little
simple here
and Let's do let's make a class here a
concrete one and let's call this
you know I'm getting to thinking about
this and I'm probably like over
complicating and making more confusing a
great thing to do this on would be path
finding if you want to switch path
finding strategies that would be a great
one because those can vary pretty
greatly depending on different things
but usually you find the best one and
stick with it so it's one of those
things too so you really got to have a
specific Niche case for this but let's
just uh let's just go off of a leveling
system so we'll say like we have a level
one type of strategy for how things are
calculated in two and three and that's
as far as we'll go so we'll go like
level one strategy
and you know if it were a game uh per se
it wouldn't be just execute it would be
like different things it'd be like
there's uh
maybe melee attack okay and then there's
let's say maybe ranged attack and it's
just gonna return an integer so
obviously there would be a little more
to this but we can get to that shortly
um let's say we pass in
an integer just called base this will be
like in all the dark base all right so
we'll have a level one strategy of of
doing these attacks then we'll do a
level two uh and so on so we're just
gonna make sure we inherit from strategy
and then we need to make sure we Define
these pure virtual methods so let's go
ahead and do that all right so we want
to just Define these and uh it's going
to get easier from here on out now that
we've kind of got a structure make sure
you put the override keyword here that
way everything knows that it's
overriding the base strategy ones there
we go all right so we do a level one
strategy we have a base and you know in
your whatever you're calling this you
might have other stuff but let's say
let's just add another thing here just
to have more fun we'll have a bonus
that'll be like maybe your weapons
damage or something because you'll have
a base or maybe your strength or who
knows what or decks but we'll say we
have to pass that in on obviously uh you
should also probably be doing these by
cons to ref uh but I'm kind of skipping
over that and in general the compiler
will probably optimize it anyway so not
a huge deal but okay so level one
strategy we just are gonna Return base
plus bonus that's it just a simple
straightforward
base plus bonus and still I'm thinking
of bass is like base weapon damage and
bonus is like your attribute or
something so pretty straightforward just
a very simple report but what about
level two so let's copy this let's make
a little what happened to level two you
want to hit a little harder right now
your stats might increase so that might
change but likely the weapon is going to
stay the same so you wanna you want uh
you know this is just all hypothetical
so you might for the level two strategy
you might say
just a plus two in there we'll just add
I had a bonus to a level two that symbol
you know we could do multiplication or
all kinds of interesting scaling stuff
but we're just going to keep it really
simple here and we're going to go for
level three and we'll just make this a
four so we're going up like two per
level and uh and that'll be there so
uh yeah I think that's good enough for
now we don't really need to do a whole
lot of other special stuff let's go to
our main and just test this out so we
got strats let's go ahead and Implement
uh
a class that uses this so we got strats
Let's uh let's just make another header
that'll be good enough to make a new
file we're just going to call this our
our player for now
let's do it all in a dot h since it's
all going to compile into this Main and
we'll just make a class called player
and we're going to do some composure
methods here I've got a lot of you guys
love the composition over inheritance so
this kind of makes use of that at least
at this part because uh say well we want
this to be private privately we're going
to have a strategy so strategy and it's
got to be a pointer so we can actually
do the dynamic changing it and uh we'll
just call it level Strat I guess very
good of course we need to include
strategy and we're not going to know
what it is or strats
all right and we want some public
methods here we want a we want to set
strategy of course set Strat and we're
just going to take a strategy pointer
easy enough
and we also want like an execute method
um well we have a tax in our case so we
could just say execute strategy um but
in our case we're gonna you know we have
two different strats in there that we
might want to call so we're going to say
melee the pack
and we'll pass into this melee attack
weapon damage or base
base damage so that might change if
you're punching with your fist you got
the base damage from your fist that's
what I'm thinking this is all
hypothetical if you've got a weapon
you're going to take the base damage
from that and the other one is going to
be like our stat bonus and you can make
that up however you want
um we're going to Define these in the
header in this case and rather than
having a bunch of C plus plus classes
yeah Strat of course is just gonna just
gonna set this let's try it now you can
see here we're not really doing the
memory management in this class so
that's assumed you're doing that
elsewhere because obviously these
planers the memory for what's in them
exists somewhere but it's kind of
assumed you have a system here we'll
probably do it in our main for now
all right so we got a melee attack and
we got a range attack now range attack
probably needs more stuff like range
increments or something but we're just
ignoring that factor for now this should
be all we need so if we do the melee
attack we're gonna go level Strat uh dot
melee attack and pass in these these
things
the bonus is this other one and it
should just execute that now it's going
to return we need some return values
here because we want the return is
basically what the final number is so we
want to make sure we get that in here so
there we go got a melee arranged attack
and as we level up we can set this now
um this definitely needs to be set keep
that in mind like if this is a null
pointer you're going to get null
references and it's going to error out
so let's just make a required
Constructor here that takes the strategy
to begin with so you gotta initialize it
with something now just to you know we
could put checks instead to make sure
it's not null but this will just save us
some time if you will so level Strat is
going to equal strap I will set it to
that pointer this might be a great case
for using shared pointers because that
would Auto manage this memory because uh
if these are shared pointers for example
I'm not going to do it here but you can
if you want to practice a little if you
make uh in your main later if you make
it a shared pointer and then you know
you pass shared pointers in here of
course you'd have to include memory and
make these shared
pointers you know like that
like I said not going to do it here but
this would be a great case someone asked
recently when you use shared pointers
it's basically when you're like using
things in multiple places because if you
think about it this level strap might be
used on a bunch of different characters
throughout the game and you don't want
to instantiate a bunch of times you want
to use the same pointer but then you got
to keep track of who's all using it so
you don't delete the real one and that's
what a shared pointer does it doesn't
delete the real one until nothing's
using it so would be a great case here
for that sort of thing but we're all
done with this player
and our strats look good now our main
this would be like the game so let's
include our player
very cool
and let's just instantiate a player
um
and the player wants a starting stress
so let's go ahead and get a strap ready
or maybe even a few straps ready so
we'll get a level one Strat L1 Strat oh
let's call it L1 now these can be
pointers if you want like so
um but they don't actually have to be
so uh you know you just got to be
careful about how you pass it around
because even when something's not a
pointer you can still get a pointer to
it to pass the things that want a
pointer you just got to be really
careful about the lifetime because these
right here will be you know they will
delete when they go out of scope which
is when the main exits so that's kind of
okay here but if they're pointers well
they'll also delete when the program
exits but they won't delete when it goes
out of scope so keep that in mind and
you probably already know that already
if you're decent with C plus plus but
just you know never hurts to get a
little more practice with pointers if
you're not sure of them so maybe try it
both ways try making this a pointer try
making a SharePoint or just some things
you could do to further your practice if
you feel like this isn't quite enough
for you or something all right so now
let's make our player uh we'll just call
it player one
and of course player one wants to be
instantiated with a pointer to some
strategy so we want to pass it level one
now obviously it's not going to accept
this because this is not a pointer but
we can go reference in a reference will
be the starting memory address which is
essentially a pointer so that should
instantiate okay and now we can go uh
maybe we'll do a little C out here we'll
just include and we'll just do some
attacks uh we'll go level one melee
attack
all right we're just going to pass in
the base as all ones for now I think
I'll put a damage here and all we want
to do is just call player one dot melee
attack
and now may when we call this melee
tackle we need to pass it some stuff now
let's just pass it once
base damage and Stat bonus
now when we call this melee attack it's
gonna of course defer to whatever
strategy we're using in that melee
attack that's that's essentially the
algorithm switching that we're
considering here
all right we'll do the same thing for
range to so you can see it although you
probably already know uh yeah
there's not much difference between
these but just for sake of example in
the show and show that you can kind of
have as many different ones as you want
and these different switches we'll go
ahead and do that all right cool
so next we probably just want to level
up and essentially for us our leveling
up is setting it to a different strategy
so we'll just make it very verbose level
up
and now the level up we want to set this
strategy now we know we made a method
called set Strat or set strategy
whatever you want to call it and we'll
just set it to level two once again we
do have to do this by reference and
there we go
so now we can call these same things and
we know that these melee and ranged are
now going to get the plus two
so if we go look at it it's going to
call use the Strat and we go look at the
Strat
it'll be this level two one now and we
can put this in debug mode when we run
it and walk through let's make sure we
update our C outs because these aren't
Dynamic they're just hard coded in right
there now we could make them Dynamic if
we really wanted to get fancy like we
could put all the C out stuff within the
strats itself and but I'm preferring to
avoid iostream in this class because I
want to keep it clean since it might be
reused a lot and whoever's reusing it
might not necessarily want IO stream in
their project if that makes sense
um all right so there we go we got a
level two attack now let's go ahead and
go to level three so another level up
and set it to level three Strat and here
we go level three level three do some
attack so what we should see is every
time after this level up we should see
that we do more damage basically I'm
going to put some new lines at the end
of this otherwise it's going to be all
jumbled together cool
so of course you know just to further
talk a little bit more you could do this
with anything you could do this with hit
points someone remind me to mute my
phone when I start recording it's not
enough to turn down the volume you have
to turn down the notification volume on
your phone which you know I always turn
down the volume but then it's like oh
notification doesn't care where your
volume is it's gonna ding all right
fully muted now
all right let's go ahead and run this I
think I kind of want to put like a just
a little C out or uh something that
frees between these level UPS so
um we're just gonna make like a let's
make a character I guess just something
to input character a sure
just so we could have like a
a point in our console where it waits
before leveling up so there we go so now
it's just gonna our console is going to
stop at this step so we'll be able to
slowly go through it and just kind of
hit enter all right so let's go ahead
and hit uh play on this strategy Let's
uh go ahead and change the name it's not
strategy FIB anymore it's plain old
Strat strategy
all right now that c make is done
parsing there switch it to strategy or
in release mode that's fine let's hit
play and let's just make sure it works
correctly there we go our first attacks
do two damage as expected our next one
we're expecting well let's hit enter so
we can level up I guess we got an invert
character there we go we gotta level up
Hoops got a little additional stuff in
there see out there I guess I could fix
that real quick
uh
there we go
let's go ahead and stop this and restart
it
okay here we go hitting play there's our
level one attacks
as expected let's go ahead and hit uh
enter
there's I guess we got to put in some
character because it's ignoring those
new lines with the CN all right uh yeah
we do four damage press a button and
level up again level three and yeah
that's that's the strategy just change
the strategy runs a different algorithm
but you're not changing anything on your
end like you still pass in the same
stuff so that's that's the cool thing
about it and really the whole point and
great for dynamic switching on the Fly
and uh yeah leave any comments down
below let me know if you learned
something feel free to practice with
those other methods like try making
these a pointer try try with shared
pointers or maybe try in your own
program with more elaborate stuff and
yeah let us know how that goes alright
see you in the next one peace out
[Music]